hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast identifying driver
alterations and therapeutic options in
cancer he's presented by Nicholas
Schultz PhD the head of knowledge
systems at the Kravis Center for
molecular oncology at the Memorial Sloan
Kettering Cancer Center I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes lab
routes is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box appears on the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Schultz I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you very much for the
introduction I'm happy to be here and be
presenting about my work and hope that
this will be useful for other people's
research so I'll talk about identifying
driver alterations and therapeutic
options in cancer and a little bit of
background I run a research lab at
Memorial sloan-kettering but I also lead
an infrastructure group that builds
systems that help researchers and
clinicians that the interpretation of
genomic variants cancer and I'll focus
mostly on those aspects in this in this
presentation this is all motivated by
the idea of what we now call precision
oncology is that we are now able to
identify alterations and tumor samples
of cancer patients use that information
to infer what kind of treatments
specific patients might be sensitive but
power really here comes from the fact
that we can now do this in depth at
individual basis meaning we can
theoretically quantify and qualify
changes in the acids and proteins or
molecules we can combine that with
pathology and radiology information and
all available clinical data but then and
then we can integrate all of that but
then the real advance comes will or will
eventually come from the fact that we
can do this over and over again on
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
patients and learn from the earth and
patients learn from how these patients
were treated and how they responded and
that's really the ultimate goal of
precision oncology and I want to say
we're in the early stages of this a lot
of what I'll talk about is examples of
focus of my presentation and the tools
that I'm showing is more on the nucleic
acid sites as well as integration and
assets a dearth from the mutations and
copy number changes and and others but
clinical data and then linking that to
personal treatments and an outcome just
as a reminder for everyone fairly simple
overview but cancer is is an event that
is based on genetic alterations that are
that genetic alterations in cells that
gives cells a growth advantage over
others these if the cells usually
acquire these alterations sequentially
alterations that give these cells growth
advantageous looks a little bit like
evolution but but much faster and happy
in the lifetime
or not over many lifetimes certain
events can increase the rate at which
these mutations accumulate accumulate
for example mutations in DNA damage our
cell cycle checkpoints and then over
time many of these alterations develop
the ones that confer a growth advantage
to cells we would refer to as drivers
and all others there are passages like
it's one challenges and I'll come back
to that that we need to distinguish
between between those two facets before
we can distinguish we need to measure we
need to detect these alterations
routinely do in clinical practice at
Memorial sloan-kettering is we use a
targeted gene panel that covers car
currently 1468 genes we called MS cane
in fact it's a tumor and matched tumor
normal a say in about 600 X sometimes it
will be more of a verage coverage across
the protein coding and examples of these
genes as well as a couple of introns and
key genes that are prone to
rearrangements and subsequent RNA fuse
for all of these patients we have a
patient consent some patients also sign
a consent for German analysis and then
after sample preparation these time just
in sequence mutations are called the
state-of-the-art bioinformatics tools
and all which case gets repeated
manually and Aryans are signed out and
been released the oncologists and
patients but also and is important for
us on the research side also released
for research purposes
test yields somatic as well as German
mutations when there's consent
somatic alterations specifically
sequence mutations are small Ariane's or
larger in Dells copy number gives
embosses the test to detect arm level
events as well as copy number change
like amplification compilations and like
I said for some games we can detect
rearrangements in solutions and I've
mentioned many patients
consent also available that also
reported back to the patient and the
patient's family this slide is just an
overview of genes that are in the SI the
first version had 341 genes and 400 mg
income is now at 468 genes run the pouch
we've run over 10,000 samples now under
460 and another 30,000 or so under
panels back to this issue of grinders
versus passengers this slide here
illustrates quite nicely that in fact
most mutations in cancer samples are
actually pathogens this slide is a slide
but Brodus the cheek caddy gets his food
five years ago where they showed
graphically data from all of the exons
that they have sequence at the time most
of these samples are cancer genome atlas
samples that another research samples
but basically each dot is a tumor tumors
are organized by tumor types from left
to right the y axis indicates the number
of mutations found in that she was
sampled normalized by the size of the
genome and it's a log scale so each tick
mark is an order of magnitude to murrs
on the left tend to be knows that
hematologic and childhood with mutation
rates of less than 1 we take a look at
megabit megabase and then to those on
the right are those that tend to be
linked to a didn't like melanoma as the
Sun that causes groceries smoking causes
mutations among cancers and you can see
that these tumors have orders of
magnitude more mutations than the ones
on the left just because they don't have
that many more mutation doesn't mean
they have many more just call passenger
mutations and the challenge really is to
identify drivers among the men who
passed another way of looking at this is
looking at an example from the AIDS now
project emails so this graph here shows
an excerpt from 78,000 occasions that
were found in 18136 patients from left
to right it shows the most frequent
mutations in the disease most treatment
and very few mutations that are frequent
candy bars g12 imitation on the very
left is the most educational under that
would 724 sample the graph is going to
be a second to K master's office third
but then you can see this curve comes
flat very quickly and shown here
actually just the 1000 most frequent
occasions on the right you have her to
occasionally of particularly senescence
9h were to find that 5/7 but as you
continue on to the right of this curve
the bottom tail you will actually notice
them out of the 78,000 60 and thousand
be taking a single mutations observe
only one patient of the core point it
doesn't necessarily mean that they are
not and that their passengers but
chances are pretty high that these are
our passengers yeah so simple method is
a long tail a lot of noise here but some
signal that's that's signal in the noise
so how can we reduce the complexity in
the data how can we find that somehow
can we find those drivers I'm going to
show three different ways of doing it
combination of the first two and first
one is returns the second one is its
prior knowledge knowing annotating
previously known information then the
third one days integrating those two and
combining those with intuitive
visualization analysis so recurrence
analysis has been saying tumor genomes
or exomes
the rodents pioneered many of those for
example to detect energy that's always
been the standard similarly for copy
number changes just think of the rhythm
plus the same they both of these
algorithm algorithm to detect altered
genes without communication level or a
copy number of them but as we're moving
deeper into cancer genomics it's also
become pretty clear that it's not just
the genes that matter it's also the
positions and genes I want to highlight
that here would be an example of Irby
twos we all know that OB 2 is a cancer
gene limits amplified specifically
breast cancer and gastric cancer and
it's also frequently mutated but if you
look at her b2 mutation is across 60,000
patients and you can see that the
mutations that we observe are scattered
across the protein you're looking at
here as a linear representation of the
protein structure where the 1255 amino
acids lined up we can see the domains
for example the kinase domain of the
domain in the right
each of these lollipops indicates the
position of mutations and the hydrogen
all apart how many many mutations all
the green ones and missense the black
ones are truncating variants of the
brown ones specifically around 2800 was
like in frame insertion solution you can
see that mutations occur in almost all
parts of the protein but many of them
are single sensitive and there are some
exceptions and those are what we call
hot spots these are mutations that more
and then returned that basically occur
more frequently and maybe you would
expect how can you how can you detect
those systemic risk showing he has an
analysis by Barry Taylor's group yes oil
suffering
initially assembled a cohort of about
10,000 tumor samples later upgraded
about 25,000 to sample came up with an
algorithm that basically looks through
all the mutations and tries to identify
the amino acid position and a more
frequently mutated than expected by
chance and by chance as a background
model that takes into account the
readability of nucleotides in the trying
to detect our next photo ability itself
as well as the observed mutations across
samples that originally they found that
p53 was the most frequently was the gene
with the most frequent hotspots of the
52 hotspots on 19 and pik3ca 14 and APC
APC and all together they found hundreds
of hot spots were made since upgraded
this to a 25,000 to analysis and now
find
eleven hundred and sixty-five hot spots
247 genes all of that information is
available through a website which be
maintained it's called cancer hotspots
in the website is cancer hotspots at
over key you can interactively go
through that website and find all of the
genes that we currently mutated deeper
and find out what the resulting you know
as a changes are and also what the
distribution is across different cancer
types for each of these mutations when
back to our be - this was and their
first randiss is about on the ten
thousands of they found six missense
hotspots and every tube you can see
highlighted here so as to be can was the
most people of midi mutations that
mutation is it seems to be more common
in bladder with 38 occurrences that we
press deliver and so forth they also
found the our sixth and main
communication levels have found in 9 :
samples and a couple of other tumor
types the l7 55 seem to be more breast
specific 22 mutations their duplication
y77
to versus non small cell lung cancers
and then to other mutations in the
kinase domain at all so the more breast
or colon enriched nice thing about all
of these hot spots is they were
eventually validated or you before you
already validated to be functional
functional experiments see the
difference right the effect and
sometimes there can be complications the
what I'm showing now is zoom in on who
we not no longer showing the most
frequent hot spots but if the acts has
not changed I'm not looking at mutations
that are that recurred at a level of
between five and ten mutations observed
and you can see now there a couple of
those are the currently significant hot
spots on one foot have the little flame
icon you can see the numbers are smaller
but they're clearly above background
another extra cellular Hospital 277 that
seems to be bladder imaged : which talks
about it that you know as a 293 he's 769
distributed nicely across different
cancer types Avenue one showed up that
wasn't quite significant and it is just
to illustrate that the numbers as we're
gonna find more and more of these
mutations as the numbers grow but we
found this one amino acid change that's
seriously five which happen only twice
but who that the samples happen to be
months on some lung cancer centers and
when we looked closely we realized that
these were v2 mutations actually occur
in we we call driver- oh my God look
there's no us not yes the first of these
examples which has cdkn2a mutation which
wasn't on drivers as the key 11 we keep
one but none of these mutations are long
drivers in the tyrosine kinase pathway
we typically expect a driver and of on
cancer cells this urban to mutations at
the time we know how to interpret is
likely the
take a mass driver in that particular
other than one small someone cancer lung
adenocarcinoma sampling which found that
mutation was very similar also not a
nice tequila keep one no other driver
and go eat you are no wrath of my wrath
so two examples that an initiative
returns will probably keep finding more
medications as we grow our deficits so
what I just showed was it was an example
of how to use returns on a linear level
you know ass isn't asking you know
assets only currently we did it we can
also do this in dimensions and we have
done this is a published by JJ tau and
medicine but other groups and similar
things where you basically take
available order protein structures of
these of cancer genes and then map
mutations found in them into
three-dimensional space and ask if they
are any three-dimensional regions that
are enriched for mutations and when we
found hundreds of additional hotspots we
call them 3d hotspots and we try to
distinguish between them in different
classes we had three types residues
green ones here are those that are
single residue hotspots
the blue ones are resonators in these
units at the bottom here ones a linked
one suppose are these are desired
amino acid position that I made today
but that closed in three-dimensional
space to know you know hotspots and then
maybe the most interesting class are
these orange ones that basically are not
associated with no hot spots but
together make effort we mentioned
husband that's listed as well on a
similar website so really not sponsored
or G is the domain for this one and I'll
show you there the sausage magenta to
support also transitive
as it scans the hospital the second way
of reducing the state of complexity is
applying prior knowledge obviously a lot
of information out there in the
literature that describes specific
mutation describes them only by a
chemical effect that these mutations we
have this protein what happens
downstream there's a lot known about the
clinical significance and maybe most
importantly for patients with these
mutations the drug sensitivities are
well-known for some of these mutations
and there's a little bit known about
many more the question was how do you
put that into clinical practice
how can an oncologist identify a driver
mutation when they see the versus what
happens to them is gain more and more
other places now with genetic testing
available for tumor samples is mutation
is identified and the oncologist now
sees the record in this case of cause
loss of the non-small cell lung cancer
case with an eruption six of one image
without a database or a detailed report
this oncologist now has to consult the
FDA guidelines that follow the NCAA
compendium has to look on PubMed to see
maybe the best decision for this patient
is that right so we are trying to do is
basically put together a database that
contains all that information and
basically assists these permissions on a
modern language obviously only ones so
there are a couple of knowledge bases
out there that annotate somatic
mutations eight of them are shown on the
slides by cancer genomes probably the
first one and the built and the
endlessly hasn't been heard called
personalized cancer medicine general has
one
Jackson labs or now Ohio State's arsenal
know the capital of interpreter and
maybe the one that I always love because
it's fully open approach is specific
from what you live where it's almost
like a Wikipedia of
a variant they were in drug sensitivity
we go where the idea is that we can
enter information the information let's
edit that it gets that's a truth has
been made fully freely publicly they
open to rest a tour of our approach
antennas cables a little bit difference
started parking in parallel with many of
these other efforts who started to our
own internal after I did I miss can call
that uncle Katie where we built a
database around gene gene annotation who
spent thousands of hours basically other
generating information um everything was
generated collected in a generational
platform that was developed in a mystery
and everything was vicodin and
gene-centric effort about we collected
different variants per gene collected
information about the effect of that
variant and then in addition for
individual tumor types collected
information about clinical implications
across different cancer types and I'll
show you what that means and our sources
that we used were basically FDA
guidelines the NCCN guidelines ASCO as
well as anything nearly all in the in
the recent literature we also trying to
asbestos we could incorporate msk
oncology best practices and to do that
we established an expert review
committee which currently has 22
clinicians who are on the committee that
review a lot of the information and give
us feedback on our data the data is in
part publicly available through a
website of algo que me org where you can
you go to that website you'll see the
current status of our annotations we
have 476 annotated almost 4000 variants
with 86 drums in sixty four cancer types
and a central piece of our annotation is
what we call our levels of evidence
system which basically tracks the
treatment implications of each mutation
with a specific level and we distinguish
between
four different levels were level one
indicates under standard therapeutic
implications and after yet level one
mutation is an FDA recognized biomarker
that's predictable response to an
fda-approved drug in a particular
indication so for example eve of these
can be melanoma or specific EGFR
mutations in lung cancer those on
everyone in level 2 is slightly below
that where these are standard of care
biomarkers predictable of response to an
fda-approved drug mostly NCCN guidelines
that's or B Rafi's affinity in lung
cancer met amplifications and Spice
mutations in lung cancer and in 3a is
one tear down where it's basically there
is promising investigational data from
clinical trials for sensitivity to this
Marcus or her two mutations they QT
pik3ca mutation and breast cancer are in
this category those are the a-levels and
then of a B are basically similar
mutations but found tumor types for
which there is not yet promising
sensitivity data so b raf this is going
to be on the thyroid would be a to be
her2 amplification in the lung cancer 2
and then similarly any of these her to
make it t mutations found in bladder or
the cancer types will be 3 d in the
number 4 is the latest alteration type
that we added where there's compelling
biological evidence or sort of
preclinical data for variant to be
sensitizing to a drug and level three
and four and four are really those
patients that or maybe neurologist
should consider enrollment in a clinical
trial available you can go to the
website and get more details about which
of the genes are in each of the
categories we have varying pages as well
that give you more information about
specific marion's they're annotation
level as well as link to PubMed IDs to
all of those here's just an overview of
the different genes that are each levels
were 14 level one genes in their level
two or twenty three level three and
sixteen level four and these numbers are
changing as we update the website about
every one or two months or so
and that data is now used internally at
an escape and it goes into the clinical
sequencing reports that patients receive
or houses receive for their patients
here's an example of a de-identified
redacted lung adenocarcinoma report
where two mutations were found through
the msk impact testing and one was the
EGFR in-frame deletion which is
annotated in this report you can see on
the right the bull's eye icon indicates
that it's a no-no likely driver and then
the green level one icon indicates that
it's a level one alteration the era of
do a sense mutation has no annotation so
this is a variance of a variant of
unknown significance and if you look at
the bottom of this report here you can
see more details about the level 1
alterations from this case this our
mutation we list the drugs that this
alteration might sensitize to as well as
a paragraph that describes the treatment
implication we've now done multiple
times in different contexts as to
basically ask across a cohort of cancer
patients from different cancer types
what is the rate of potential
actionability across different cancer
types and when we do this we we find
that gastrointestinal stromal tumors of
gists
are the tumor type basically with the
highest frequency of actionable tumors
for 75% of alteration of tumors have at
least one level one or two a alteration
in that tumor type and those are chip
mutations for the most part die red
cancer has a lot fewer of these has no
level 1 alterations but has a lot of
level 2b mutations of the BRFSS entity
and then a lot of 3a and then breast
stands out in the way in the sense that
it has the highest proportion of level 3
r3a alterations so almost 50 percent of
breast cancers are level 3a because they
Harbor pik3ca mutations akt mutations or
RB 2 mutations the
to amplifications our make up this
bottom 15% or so that our level one and
then if you go down this this this list
of two attacks you can see on the right
there are a couple of tumor types that
have very few potentially actionable
alterations that at our current state of
knowledge while a lot of tumor types in
the middle have only those that we call
the B levels where these alterations
sensitized to certain drugs and other
cancer types but it's not yet proven or
known that these same alterations
sensitized to the same drugs in these
tumor types
so the last part of this presentation
will be showing you how we try to tie
all of those different pieces of
information together in intuitive
visualization and analysis tools so what
we are or we have been building over the
last 10 years and this really started
with the Cancer Genome Atlas was a
system that we call the cbio portal for
cancer genomics and this we started
building this at the very first TCGA
project that was Cleo bust told me at
the time but even though compared to
what we have now this was a relatively
small data set it was already clear to
us then that the scale of the data was
just more than most biologists and
clinicians could and should handle it
was only 91 samples at the time that
were profiled but before each sample we
had mutation data copy number data mRNA
methylation clinical data and that data
really just was presented to to the
researchers in spreadsheets and text
files or in spreadsheets and that was
pretty clear that there were some
bioinformatics folks that could analyze
this data but most of the researchers
and clinicians that the ones that were
really equipped to interpret the data
they couldn't actually handle the data
computation around doing that and Excel
spreadsheets was just not not a way to
go so we thought of ways to make to
bridge that gap and we started building
the Cir portal and we put the data into
a database and then a people easy access
to the data initially just really
downloading slices of the data
downloading just a few genes and a few
samples as opposed to having to download
matrices of 20,000 genes x 91 samples
but then fairly quickly we started
layering all these different
visualizations on top of it and you can
see some of them here in our later show
in a little life video what that what
what the core looks like and actually a
couple of years ago we made an important
step and that was that we we made the
cbio portal open source that means we
released the all of the software code
for the software publicly made it made
it available for
anybody to use and to modify so anybody
can go to github and look at the codes
download the code and solve it locally
but also make modifications the only
thing we ask and this is we make sure
that this happens via the a GPL license
that is that all modifications are
contributed back so that anybody can
benefit from the modifications and this
has worked really well in the software
is now developed and maintained at
multiple institutions or led by biostat
msk and ethan ceramics with the
dana-farber but also done in
collaboration with Princess Margaret
chopped Cornell and then the high F and
hydras are small bioinformatics company
in the Netherlands that really builds
solutions around open source software
they have helped us tremendously they
helped Pharma clients to want to set up
local versions of the see my report or
who want to develop features for the
portal they consult very closely with us
and as a result the portal is now
installed at dozens of institutions
across the world including including
many companies and these maps here
really I think I just took up the
iceberg that show you where in the US
and around the world we have versions of
the C vipole that we know about maybe
more informative is the graph on the
left that tracks the number of unique
users that we have and that's growing
year by year number of help requests
that we're getting through a Google
Group and we've now made efforts to
really respond to all of these user
queries and we've gotten much much
better at that and then also the number
of citations that the portal has been
getting in the scientific literature and
of public psychics that see by important
org has currently about 36,000 samples
that are available for revealing and
I'll show you how some of that works in
my my demo and in a minute or so and
this slide just really illustrates how
we're using the C bio problem is K but
it's representative of how any other
center that uses the data for mining of
their own internal private day that
would use it so dana-farber has a
similar system
many pharma companies have it many other
research centers and hospitals as well
so we obviously at the on the left side
here you have the TCGA data the ICGC
data and other public data which we
curate from the literature and put into
the by see by important that's available
to anybody yet see by our portal dot
o-r-g but we also have pipelines that
can handle foundation medical data and
feed that into the portal make it
available to our researchers and then
everything that is comes out of the
center from electron ecology for
research sequencing as well as clinical
sequencing is also moved into C by a
portal and in real times or a moment
sample sequence it gets entered into
this you buy a portal where it can then
be visualized and a bigger challenge for
us is currently to bring in the match
single clinical data or genomic data is
by definition structure that we are
trying to find ways to bring in or
automate its clinical annotation about
these samples
the current model that still works the
best this is really working with a
clinician an RSA a med student or
something that someone similar and
collecting data manually and putting in
spreadsheets that still works but as
we're now approaching 30,000 sequence
clinical samples we gets harder and
harder so we really have to improve our
our ability to automate transform go
upstream automatic capture and then just
to tie it all together from the right of
the slighty
you see the information that i've talked
about earlier and my presentations see
my authority also has annotation layer
it's bringing information from Uncle KP
for example but also for me from the
Civic database about the variant effect
and therapeutic options about individual
variants and that is shown in many
different places of the key used
interactively as well as information
from cancer hotspots and the cosmic
database on on recurrence
and in the last part of this
demonstration I will just show a live
demo of how this is biophoton works and
I want to through a couple of examples
of how to interact with the flow of how
you can start a query from how to study
the end which is a review of samples
across a cohort and and how you can dive
deeper into across cohort analysis or
even go all the way down into this
single patients if you can see all
samples associated patient along with
clinical data only don't you information
for all of my examples of to see bio
portal I will use the public site which
is accessible at sea by a portal data
orgy and I will be using Google Chrome
which is our preferred browser but the
portal also supports Firefox as well as
Safari Internet Explorer we really can't
guarantee that it will work newer
versions should work older versions
definitely don't when you come to the
public site you will see on the left you
see an overview of tissue types from
which you can select cancer studies and
on the right you see a full overview of
all the studies in the portal and there
216 studies currently so you can scroll
down here and see all the different
studies number of samples sources etc
very useful as this little field up here
where I couldn't start searching and I'm
looking for the TCGA pan-cancer Atlas
data set and for this example so when I
type TCGA pan-cancer Atlas I get thirty
three matching studies I can select them
here with one click and then scroll down
to select mutations and copy number
which is the default look at all samples
and then I enter my gene or genes of
interests in this example I want to go
back to the erbb2 example from earlier
in my presentation to show you how you
can visualize the data that I showed in
real time in the sea bio portal so I
enter my gene I hate to submit and what
the portal now does it is go it goes
through
these 33 studies and looks for
alterations in the erbb2 in each of
those studies and then summarizes them
across studies and by alterations the
portal considers for alteration types
number one is mutations these are
somatic mutations nonsynonymous 2 is
amplifications 3 is deletions and 4 is
gene rearrangements of fusions so what
you're looking at here now is a bar
graph that shows you the alteration
frequencies of erbb2 across different
cancer types sorted from left to right
by decreasing frequencies so it's alpha
GL cancer is the cancer type with the
highest alteration rate followed by a
stomach and bladder but you can also see
in addition to this tailing off here
were a couple of kinds of types on the
rest like on the right like mesothelioma
or chromophobe kidney have no
alterations whatsoever any RPP - but you
can also see is the types and the
patterns of alterations so esophageal
and stomach is dominated by the red part
at the bar which reflects the
amplifications and when you hover over
you can see frequencies for each of the
events so 11% of esophageal cancer is
has an EB - amplification but only 2.75
percent haven't have a mutation that
pattern shifts a little bit in bladder
where we see 11 percent mutation
frequency but only four percent
amplification frequency and it may be
most pronounced melanoma has a mutation
frequency of 7 percent but no
amplifications whatsoever and what
you're looking at here at the top is the
lollipop diagram that same linear domain
structure 1255 amino acids and then
mutations dotted along that axis you can
see the clustering of mutations and the
kinase domain over here you can see that
extracellular hotspot at s 310 and then
below you see a table that shows for
each mutation the study or the cancer
type that was found in the sample ID
cancer type spelled out as well as the
exact amino acids change annotations
which will come back to the type of
mutation missense the copy number status
of that gene in that sample
the cosmic count meaning the number of
times that particular mutation was seen
in cosmic the allele frequency which
shows you what the read covered was in
that TCGA sample and how many of the
reads supported the mutation so in this
example it's a 42 percent allele
frequency at 13 out of 31 variants
supporting the mutation and then last is
the number of mutations found in that
sample altogether which is a good
indicator for whether or not a sample
might be hyper mutated or not and then
back to the annotation column this is
now tying in some of the resources I
showed earlier so this v8 42i mutation
for example is labeled here with the
blue bullseye which indicates that it's
a driver event according to uncle KB and
it has a level number associated with it
indicating that's a level of 3
alteration and you can hover over that
and now see more information about that
mutation including an explanation for
why it's a gain of function mutation
including two references here that are
linked as well as more information about
the level of alteration and the drug
that the drug or drugs that this
mutation might sensitize to including
citations for the sensitivity we also
have information from the Civic database
here next to it and you can click on on
these links and it'll it'll take you to
Civic my cancer genome is linked and
then any mutation that is a
statistically recurrent hotspot
according to cancer hot spots that Awaji
also has this little flame icon you can
now interact with the table on the top
and for example click on any of these
mutations oh I'm sorry but the lollipop
plot on top and then the bottom table
updates and filters basically to what
what do you have selected you can
unselect these changes you can also
click over here and say show me only the
missense mutations we're setting the
filters is here or show me only the
in-frame mutations and you can see
they're a very few but they're all
clustered in this one region and the
kinase domain and many of them are in
lung cancer samples which you can see
down here and then the last thing I
wanted to show here is how to filter
this table base and the lollipop diagram
based on this little search box so you
can go in here now and
- breasts and it'll show you all the
breast cancer mutations and you can
nicely see the pattern of clustering of
mutations and the kinase domain the most
common one is the ll 755 mutation
colorectal will probably look similar :
where you can see kinase domain
mutations including the v7 7/7 bladder
will look different where we have a lot
of these extracellular domain mutations
and still a couple of kinase domain
mutations and then maybe last as long
where we expect to see these in frame
insertions and deletions in the in the
kinase domain and for my next example
and back at the home page and I'm now
looking at the msk impact clinical
sequencing cohort study that is the
first study that everybody sees and as
10,000 945 samples and I'm clicking on
this little icon here to study summary
and that takes me to a new a different
page which is a summary of all the
genomic alterations as well as clinical
attributes of samples in that cohort
this is a cohort that consists of
multiple different cancer types so it
looks a little bit different than many
other studies so there
10900 45 samples from 10,000 336
patients the samples break down by
cancer type and the following way when
we have 1,600 and more non small cell
lung cancer samples 1,300 breast cancer
samples and you can see the list goes on
some of the rarer tumor types are at the
bottom here mesothelioma for example we
have a hundred and seven and some of
them are very rare and are only scarcely
represented the diagram on the right
here represents the number of mutations
found in each sample on the y-axis and
degree of copy number changes on the
x-axis each dot is a tumor samples so
tumors up here have a low copy number
burden copy number alteration burden but
very high mutation count and these
samples over here have a very low
mutation burden but a very high fraction
of the genome is altered by copy number
changes
that this is a summary now of the gene
mutation frequency so T p53 is the most
frequently mutated gene in this msk
impact cord and as a reminder this is
the targeted gene sequencing cohort that
has no more than 468 gene sequenced 41
percent of the samples have a TPP tp53
mutation 15 percent of a chaos' mutation
and 13 percent of a mutation most of
these are tert promoter mutations and
then twelve percent of a pik3ca mutation
the next table shows you copy number
changes so the most frequent deletion is
that of cdkn2a and be on chromosome 9 P
which happens in about seven percent of
our cohort and the most frequent
amplification is cyclin d1 followed by
making RB to which all occur at about
four percent there's more information
here for example the sex distribution of
the cohort is about 50/50 we have the
patient's vital status live deceased we
have sample types whether a primary or
metastasis was was analyzed and and many
more pieces of information this entire
page is interactive so I can go in here
now and select the non small cell lung
cancer samples and now this cancer type
detailed table becomes relevant because
I can now go in further and decide
whether I'm interested in long I have no
cars no more squamous on small cells I'm
selecting lung adenocarcinoma in this
example so 1,300 samples adenocarcinoma
you can see the red samples now indicate
show you the mutation burden in these
samples which is lower than some of
these really hypermutated ones but some
outliers here of high mutation burden
and now all the tables and charts have
updated and you can see T 53 is still
the most frequently mutated gene in this
cohort 51 percent followed by Kira's
EGFR SDK 11 and and keep one
amplifications
deletions have changed a little bit EGFR
has not moved up to the most frequently
copying involved a gene of 8%
so I can now start using this page to
select genes I can select them here and
when I select them they show up up here
in this in this little box I can also
search for genes we're going up to
therapy to earlier so I can find out B
to here click on it select it and then
you can enter more genes over here so
I'm actually going to rearrange this
just a little bit and show you a couple
of other genes red cross and Alec are
the ones that are altered by fusions
frequently I'm going to move chaos over
here and nf1 b-raf and map to k1 so
these are sort of driver genes that are
very well-known in lung cancer and then
I click the query button and that will
take me to a new view and that is what
we call the aqua print the Algar print
will show you the genes you've selected
from top to bottom and then the samples
that you've selected this case 1269 lung
adenocarcinoma samples in this cohort
and then this basically is like a matrix
of genes versus patients I'm just
zooming out so that you can see the
entire cord cord all at once what you
can now see is the frequencies of each
gene at which they're altered and the
types of events in in those genes so
EGFR is alter than 30% but those 30% are
broken down into samples that have the
green ones and missense mutations the
darker red ones here the brown ones are
in-frame insertions and deletions the
tall red rectangles are amplifications
and then you can see combinations of
mutations and amplifications and the
purple ones here are rearrangements or
or gene fusions the black dots here are
truncating mutations or in this
particular case splice site mutations
which actually lead to in frame splicing
events and met but here and if one has a
couple of these truncating events and
you can add some clinical tracks here or
other genomic data track so I'm adding
total number of mutations here on top
and what you can now appreciate is how
the overall mutation burden in a sample
but some of the mutations that we see so
I introduced the and the alkyl KP
database earlier as well as cancer
hotspots and you can see that each
mutation he has annotated with respect
to whether or not that mutation is is
known a non-driver either by uncle poppy
or by cancer hotspots and there are a
couple of mutations over here that are
light green so those are missense
mutations that are not known to be
drivers so you can see a couple of them
in use you have ARP you see a couple of
them here in red and then Ross and Alec
and Alec is a very long gene so you
expect to see more of them and you can
nicely see if you track this line all
the way to the top here that many of
these mutations actually track with the
increased mutation burden which is what
you would expect a hyper me to the tumor
has more passenger mutations but it also
tends to be the sample so if you look
down here at Kira's now where these D
samples have other events so this mutual
exclusivity to you that you expect in
lung cancer samples this is not quite
there because of these samples but you
can modify any of what you want to
display here you can choose to deselect
uncle Kb driver annotation or hotspot
you can implement simple counts whether
you want the the counter just be across
C by a portal or use the cosmic counts
but you can go as far as hiding the
variants of unknown significance and if
I do that the aqua print will rerender
and will now show me a much cleaner
version where all of these V us's are
missing and you can see the mutual
exclusivity across the cohort looks much
better where most of the Kaos mutations
but the exception of and if one which is
well known don't overlap with any of the
other driver cases in lung
adenocarcinoma
and with that I want to acknowledge all
the different people involved if it
works we might miss Kay JJ cow who meets
the CIO for my luck it will be front-end
development the backend development is
important in Chakrabarty who meet
scientists or uncle KP if solids
collaborators let normal super great
because their ami and assign their [ __ ]
Farber and then obviously the clinical
leadership at MSG is this possible thank
you very much thank you dr. Schultz for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started the
first question is is there a way I can
visualize my own data in the CIO portal
that's a great question sweet we don't
unfortunately don't have a way yet where
you can just click one button and upload
the data set and see that data set all
the way through by a portal the way that
we have pre curated for you but there
are a couple of options one of them is
we have a couple of tools that you can
use that are on the website where you
can upload little bits of data so for
example we have a way where you can
upload a mutation file and you get a
lollipop clock they thought that I
showed earlier with all the different
locations across the domain structure or
Naga prints
you saw the applicants in the video you
can get an encore print if you found if
you upload your data and the right
format all of the other things that I
show they're currently not available
that way other option is that you can
found at a local version install a local
version of see bio portal but that
requires that have some system
administrators
oh maybe best for everybody is you talk
to someone at the institution and maybe
set up a local version of C by a portal
for the entire institution software is
free
obviously the maintenance requires some
work so you need someone skilled at the
institution what's that system for you
and you can start small leave that one
alone will eventually put it on an on a
bigger circle and in the cloud and we're
happy to help with there are questions
about how to read the documentation
around that thank you it's uncle KD
freely available for use by others yes
and no so it's a little bit tricky so
uncle KB is great fully available and by
many different publications out there so
for research use it's really available
with no restrictions whatsoever but we
currently have don't have the ability to
license it for commercial use or for use
in patient annotation so that's
something that hopefully will change in
the future but currently we don't have a
way to thank you me attempt for one more
question
it looks like the spectrum or Irby b2
mutation differs across two more types
do we know yet which of these mutations
sensitized to her two inhibitors and are
there differences between specific
mutations and tumor types hotspots
across there between the main structure
it was pretty clear that the
distribution across different cancer
types is not random or the estimate NFB
patient much more common in bladder and
other cancer types and then breast
cancers I don't have more commonly have
mutations in the kinase domain and
correct those do too but it looks like
the different not the same on small cell
lung cancer you saw have these inflamed
insertions and deletions the kinase
domains
it's clear that there are different
patterns across cancer types
Ratliff study the early results that was
came out show quite convincingly that
breast cancer samples and to respond
better to her to inhibitors but there
was not yet
well I think not not much data yet that
shows that the other cancers had to
respond better but there's probably also
not enough data yet so I think the
numbers are so small we really need
there's many more treated patients that
put under her 2 inhibitor specifically
because the mutation so that over time
our body of data grows to the point
where we can actually stratify response
analysis not just by you didn't or not
but also by it in what cancer type which
particular mutation and then maybe more
importantly after that what's the
communicational context which other
genes are mutated in what way in the
same sample so that maybe those patients
respond better that had no other
alterations in the same or similar
pathway versus those that did I think we
really need more data to answer that
question I'm going to take time for one
more question are there any new features
on the horizon for the C bio portal yes
we have we're working on a lot of our
future development was slowed down a
little bit by the need to really
architect IV into the entire some bio
portals of the bio photo has been
growing for 10 years now you can imagine
like anything you build build on top of
all things and eventually things just
don't work as efficiently anymore and
what we decided to do by the year so ago
is to basically we engineer the entire
software and bring it up to 28
software engineering standards that was
being fluent took some time but I think
in the next two months or so we finished
without and you look at our news last
year you can mentally updated there's a
piece of the portal at the expense of
not being able to
a new feature is have a lot of those
most exciting one is allowing users to
select subgroups of samples and asking
the portal the differences between them
which genes are differentially primary
them does that example it's just one
example of many more that are coming you
can certainly send them along to us well
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Schultz for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September 21st 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
bye